first up he is the congressional
representative who's tested Texas Texas
district say that three times
who's Texas district crosses the most
land on our southern border from Texas
as eighth District we'll heard ladies
[Applause]
thank you very much for being here and
yes let's talk about your district it's
I understand 820 miles long width of the
border
I represent 29 counties to timezones
it's larger than 26 states roughly the
size of Georgia
it must be nobody in it right must be
very sparse so there's there's more
thousand people in between San Antonio
then to El Paso right I'm from San
Antonio that's the biggest city and 820
miles of the border it's a 71 percent
Latino district and it's it's truly the
only 50/50 district in Texas 50%
Republican 50% Democrat and I bet you
the people think you're a Democrat but I
try to talk about things that make sense
like border security and since I have
more border than any other member of
Congress I'm the only Republican that
represents a part of the border there's
there's a 9 right Congress that
represent the border all Democrats that
for me and I have the most almost
two-thirds of the border between the
u.s. and Mexico and you've called
Trump's wall a myth right the need for a
wall well I've said that when saying
that this is hasn't been a problem for
multiple administration's that's a myth
but I do believe building a 30-foot high
concrete structure that takes three
hours to penetrate from sea to shining
sea is the most expensive and least
effective way to do border security
well let's talk about what might be a
myth in this area is the fact that
immigration is a big problem I think is
a myth do you think immigration is even
a top-10 problem in America one of our
top ten biggest problems last year
400,000 people came to our country
illegally and that's a decrease of 80
percent since 2000 so but 400,000 is
still a lot of people I actually think
when you when you're at three point nine
four percent unemployment guess what you
need people to work like that's why we
should solve the daca problem there's
1.2 million young men and women who have
only known the United States of America
has our home these are people that are
contributing to our economy to our
culture to our society there are already
Americans let's keep him here let's have
a permanent sir would it be a top-ten
problem for that for the docket for the
docket kids of the dreamers it seems to
me like it's not a problem it's almost a
solution because people there are a lot
most Americans will not do the jobs that
the people who are coming over the
border will do that seems like a win-win
look I think it's an opportunity right
immigration is actually an opportunity
to make sure that we have people in and
when you're at three point nine four
percent unemployment guess what you need
workers whether it's agriculture or
artificial intelligence so we should be
streamlining our our immigration process
in order to make sure that we have the
workforce that we need in order to keep
our economy go so are you a Republican
like through your parents historically
I'm just asking why you're a Republican
anyone is any party I'm not I'm a
Republican because I believe in limited
government I'm a Republican because I
believe they don't do that I'm a
Republican because I believe in economic
opportunity right do that even but there
are some warts there are some warts on
the party but also you can say the same
like the others but but here's where I
think we should get to right instead of
talking about all the things that
divides us let's talk about those things
that actually unify us because I've
crisscross 20 I don't do that either I'm
just asking why you're a Republican
because they're not good at the debt
that was their big thing you said
limited government they don't do that
they took over the Congress in 2011 and
they raised the debt a trillion dollars
a year they're not good at national
defense the president's a traitor what's
in it for you why what is what is in the
Republican Party for you I will say this
you were in the CIA I was in the CIA for
almost a decade
I was the dude in the back alleys at
four o'clock in the morning collecting
intelligence on threats to the homeland
I did a collective I didn't buy his
jacket but I did two years in India two
years in in Pakistan I did two years in
New York City doing a lot of interagency
work and then a year and a half in
Afghanistan where I managed all of our
undercover operations okay so what do
you think when you see the President of
the United States this week belittling
our intelligence choose what it it
erodes trust in our institutions I it
makes it makes arm
[Applause]
I believe think when they see us we're
not with airing our dirty laundry
fighting amongst ourselves what do they
think when the president doesn't they
know our president doesn't believe the
experts they know the experts are right
they're not crazy
new rule the president should listen the
president should listen to the
intelligence chiefs right
[Applause]
and so so so so I would agree but it
does a road things because what let's
take Russia for example yes trying to
manipulate our elections in in 2016
why something else he denies so they
they're trying to erode trust in our
democratic institutions yes Russia is
not a global player they're a regional
thug and they're trying to re-establish
the territorial integrity of the old
USSR and what's getting in the way a
little thing called NATO what's
supporting nato a little thing called
the united states of america right
that's why they're trying to go after us
and when we when when our president
makes this decision or goes on twitter
and criticizes the intelligence
community what happens when they're
trying to do work in the middle east
going against isis going against
al-qaeda which has metastasized to other
parts of the Middle East and northern
Africa when we have to work with our
partners it makes it more difficult for
those men and women that are in those
dark corners in those dangerous places
right I mean this was came about because
every year we get a threat assessment
right they were giving us what they say
and this is great where that we do this
and it's in writing right televised and
televised right and he said they didn't
say it now aside from the lies the
threats
I think they identified accurately you
know they said Russia is still meddling
Isis is still around all things which he
denies but it's the biggest threat him
isn't the biggest security threat to
America the president of the United
States
I think the biggest threat to long-term
stability United States is actually
China China is trying to surpass the
United States as the global hegemon but
I will say this when we when we a road
trust in our intelligence community in
our federal law enforcement that has an
impact through the rest of the world the
only way that we're going to continue to
deal with China is by making sure we
have allies when our allies can't trust
us they don't know whether if they think
there's a disconnect between what the
executive branch says and what the the
working folks whether it's in the State
Department or the CIA that is a problem
that's why that's why I speak out that's
why I try to articulate news concerns
because there's only three of us that
I've ever spent time in the intelligence
community and that are now in Congress
and this is why I speak up and try to
articulate what we should be doing but I
feel like if you are really speaking up
you would speak out against the
President and you would break with him
do you do you think I do I wrote a
little op-ed about the Helsinki decision
and when he was standing up there
next to Vladimir Putin and I said I
never would have thought at all my time
as an undercover officer in the CIA that
I would see a US president getting
played by the Russian KGB all right and
so so the next thing you say is we have
to impeach this president we have to
somehow get rid of this president do you
honestly think this president puts
country first which is what you did in
the CIA I mean more than anybody because
you guys do it anonymously my job I
agree when I agree I disagree when I
disagree and this is for me
making sure the men and women that I
served alongside with that are still
fighting wars you know we've been
finding the global war on terrorism for
17 years these men and women I speak out
on behalf of them and ultimately there's
gonna be election in 2020 where the
American people may 9 I'd are all these
all these issues I know that in your
first two years of the Trump
administration you voted with the most
of the time but
in this year you've not voted with them
at all right I think over 12 well that
number is a little misleading by the way
last Congress we had almost a thousand
bills I think it was like nine thousand
nine hundred and sixty-seven and guess
what all but 15 we're done in a
bipartisan way nobody talks about that
number you've probably never heard that
number and so that that that stats is
cherry-pick certain pieces of
legislation that you may or may not have
voted on it's not the entire I was
trying to give you it out not really
with trouble why do you want to be on
the side of this and I I agree when I
agree I disagree when I when I disagree
all right and we're going to continue to
ultimately do that in in this issue
right now with border security I think
is a perfect example of that making sure
that we're supporting dreamers is is
another area that we're going to
continue supporting I'm gonna always
make sure that I have the the backs of
the men and women in our intelligence
right well thank you for your service
you're also a brave man to come here
thank you all right
you